(dramatic music)
(mumbling)
- Find out on this Weekly Vee.
If you do not love losing
you lost.
♪ I feel I cannot lose ♪
♪ Immortal, immortal, immoral ♪
- What advice do you have
for people when it comes to
starting and especially if
they're met with negativity
that they're told no this is
something that you can't do.
- Learn to love to lose.
(soft music)
Like that's the whole
punchline of everything
I believe in.
I love losing.
Here's why,
if I went at 16 to start
a charity to raise 40,000
and I did it, they were right,
and I appreciate the
experience of that loss.
I adore losing 'cause it's fair.
You actually talked a big game
and you were wrong.
You were naive and young,
and you deserve that loss.
- I love how you smiled
talking about losing.
(laughing)
- I'm sure if we look
back at all of my content,
I'm not excited about winning,
like it's why I even jumped in and said,
no, no, I don't relate with that, right?
I relate with losing.
I like underdogs.
I can watch a sporting
event that I have no vested
interest in, come in, start
rooting for the underdog,
and then as the underdog's
winning and looks like
they're gonna win, reverse back
to rooting for the favorite,
like I'm always rooting for
whoever's in the worst spot.
Here's my thing,
if anybody has won,
that comes from your circumstance
you then have to acknowledge
that it's possible.
People deploy things like
luck, of course look,
you were adopted.
I was born in the Soviet Union,
and was able to immigrate
to America during this
one small window where out of hundreds
of millions of people,
300,000 were able to
leave during that era.
Of course.
But everything's of course.
When people are like you're lucky,
I'm like you're lucky you were born.
400 trillion to one for you to be human,
like where do you wanna
start this luck game?
Like my big thing is that the internet
has created a world that far exceeds
the opportunities that we've ever seen.
My big thing is do you wanna dwell
and excuse your way through life,
or do you wanna become accountable
and optimistic your way through life.
To me, accountability and
optimism is just far more
interesting and more challenging,
and more worth while, and less regretful
when you're 90, than blame and excuses,
and complaining and crying about it.
Ultimately because nobody's
listening to you cry.
You think they are.
Maybe your mom, maybe some
other losing, crying player,
but like, and by the way,
and I hope everybody hears me very clear,
that doesn't dismiss the fact that
white males in America that
are born into high net worth
organizations, families.
(laughing)
Families, don't have a
financial advantage.
I would argue that from what I've observed
a lot of those people end up losing
because they started with the advantage
and that is what made them soft
or insecure which led to their losing,
even though they may have more stuff.
People are like, when I talk about this,
people are like yeah
well look at their stuff,
or look how they live, I'm
like but they're not happy.
Do you want a Mercedes
and you're deeply unhappy
and doing cocaine to escape your problems
or do you want a Honda and be pumped.
And a lot of people answer
Mercedes and unhappy
'cause they're fucking stupid.
Because they don't have that right now
and they think.
But like, think about
how many times in life
you said if I only, and
then when you get there
it's not as delicious as you thought.
- All right so this morning,
you had this time that G just
got done with his podcast,
and then the rest of
the day was just a lot
of client stuff that we
weren't able to film.
So what I'm actually gonna do right now,
is kinda walk you through
his day on Instagram.
What he posted and
kinda why it was posted.
So we typically do like two videos,
one in the morning, one at night,
and then two images in between,
if you guys notice we
consistently probably post
like four times a day.
The Monday morning video we
always try to make a very
strong piece of content.
And the one that we posted
this Monday hit 1.3 million.
We kinda knew it would hit over a million
just 'cause we have some
sort of testing that we do
with all content before
we put it on his page,
so he can feel confident about
when we have a good video,
why we're posting it.
The next thing that he posted
was a Twitter style image.
Again this was also tested
on another platform.
We probably test five to 10 images a day,
and then pick the top two
and put those on Instagram.
So this is the one that he picked.
It's a simple Twitter style BSU,
you guys have seen a lot of those,
and we're seeing good
performance out of them
so we'll continue to kinda
try to ride that wave.
And then this one was kinda interesting.
So in the afternoon he posted,
through up picture of himself.
So he's definitely still
involved in like what content
we're posting, it's not
just us completely feeding
him everything, he'll go rogue,
he'll post his own stuff.
And this one he's
actually razzing on DRock,
which is always something he likes to do.
Always performs pretty well.
So if you guys remember this one?
He did that all himself,
found it, shot it, posted it.
He's still very involved.
And then later that night
he's gonna roll to the
National Title game,
takes the picture with AJ,
and we're gonna run
that footage right now,
so hope you enjoy.
And that's a bit of the process.
And on to the championship game.
(upbeat music)
[AJ] I heard that.
- [Gary] You heard that?
- [AJ] I did.
There's Sting.
Let's go bro.
- It's good, you just signed
my war dog last night man,
congratulations, solid.
- [Gary] Thank you.
He's confused.
- Gary!
Great to see you my man.
- [Gary] Thank you man,
thank you so much.
- [Interviewer] Any predictions AJ?
- I'm gonna keep it neutral.
- Payin.
(crowd cheering)
Holy shit.
What's up weekly blog, Weekly Vee,
whatever the fuck we're calling it,
it's Tuesday 12:02.
The reason I'm grumpy is,
I was in the National
Championship game last night,
then went out and did some work with AJ
for Vayner Sports, got
home to the hotel at three,
was supposed to have
a 5:20 A.M. alarm set,
I swore I set it, I'm pretty consistent,
I've been doing this
for over a decade but,
somehow it didn't happen.
Hotel rings, it's 6:05, my
flight done boarding at 6:45,
I'm in the bed at 6:05.
The airport is 27 minutes away.
So I started, you know
obviously rush the fuck
out of the hotel.
Get to the car.
Drive.
There's a fucking accident.
Which just kinda killed any of my prayers
of like him driving 100 miles an hour.
Which I don't necessary recommend.
And some hap, big shout out to CLEAR,
if you don't have CLEAR in the airport,
that fucking thing saved me today,
because there was no other flights,
there was no other connecting,
like I'd be in New Orleans right now
with my whole day fucked.
Got on the field after LSU won last night,
that was ridiculous.
There's some content,
I'm sure you probably just saw it,
I don't know how they montage this shit
now that we do Weekly Vee,
but that was yesterday and (mumbles).
I'll let you guys figure that out.
Now in a meeting with
a Jim, Zaine, May, Andy
talking about segmentation
within community,
the texting platform.
Have a bunch of meetings today.
Internal shit.
E-commerce capabilities.
Staffing issues.
CEO life.
♪ Tell them tools ♪
♪ I cut off my woman but
know I got plenty more ♪
♪ I ball with my young bull
like I'm Derrick Rose ♪
♪ I hope you know behind
these closed doors ♪
♪ Lil' baby a freak freak ♪
- [Juwan] Yo!
- What's good bro?
I'm about to do a carousel
post on my Instagram
with the guys that we've signed so far,
so I'm gonna screenshot
us talking on FaceTime.
- [Juwan] All right cool man--
- So look pretty bro.
Look pretty bro.
You better look pretty bro.
- [Juwan] C'mon man I gotta
look pretty in Florida,
you know I do.
- I know man.
Hey listen I'm so excited to announce man.
I'm gonna text these photos to you too
if you wanna post on your gram.
Hit me up when you need me, okay?
- [Juwan] Gotcha, appreciate you.
- All right gotcha bro, buh bye.
- [Juwan] Sup'.
- Juwan Johnson.
- [Man] Who was that Gary?
- That's Juwan Johnson.
We just announced him.
Former Penn State receiver
transferred to Oregon,
he got the game winning first down
in the Rose Bowl this year.
We just announced him.
Really good wide receiving prospect,
good get for Vayner Sports.
Even better, he's such a great kid,
and two great programs
like Penn State and Oregon,
all the kids in the locker room
know this is a real guy.
So like who he chose to
go professional with,
is a really big look for AJ,
it's a big, big get for AJ.
This is AJ's first year as certified,
a lot of fun fact there.
I don't know if all of people
who follow me don't realize
is that AJ was more in the position as me
the last two and a half,
three years of Vayner,
just being the Executive,
the CEO, like running it.
But this last year he
decided to get certified
because a lot of the kids
wanted to go with him,
and no negativity to the
agents we have on our squad
they just were more connected to AJ,
and then would go other places
'cause they felt a little
more connected to the agent
than the agent that we had,
and so we just thought there
was arbitrage there, so.
AJ became certified.
(upbeat music)
(people talking)
Are we all here?
- [Jason] Ready?
- No.
- On three, two, one.
One more.
Three, two, one.
Cool.
We can do the five.
(laughing)
Three, two, one.
Thank you.
- Thank you guys.
(cheering)
Thank you.
- Send some cards for the holiday,
holiday cards to Jen
Morgan and Alisha Tilman.
- Okay.
- If it's easier to stop at your desk.
- That's fine, we can do it right here.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- That was a photo for
the agency of the year.
Best places to work or.
I don't know what it was.
But yeah we're winning a lot
of awards here at Vayner, so.
- [Drock] This is such a good clip.
Wow.
- Which one Drock?
- Wow, all of them.
- [Gary] Which one?
- You're at the (mumbles).
Made in New York Pizza.
- Me and what?
- Made in New York Pizza.
- What about this?
- Her name is Arika.
- Arika?
Is it funny?
- No it's viral.
- Oh it's viral.
Oh it's viral guys.
(upbeat music)
- Actually a quick question for Daily Vee.
- Yes.
- Or Weekly Vee.
- What do you mean you said--
- A Weekly Vee real quick
'cause I know we're now
doing a whole new thing.
I'm sure Caleb's here,
gonna use some quick little
clips from this.
Oh this is my best friend,
Breman who runs Wine Library.
Yes he makes an appearance in the blog
that makes me happy.
You made an appearance in the sports card
episode too Breman.
This is as good as it gets.
It's fucking Wednesday.
We sold 100 cases of Cab.
- Yes.
- Run a baseball card show.
- By the way, Weekly Vee,
if you've not signed up
for Wine Text, like Caleb
I want you to post produce,
like cover my face here, winetext.com.
Now just like I was saying to Caleb,
maybe you use that clip,
being signed up from it
does not do me any favors.
It costs us two cents or
something to send a text.
But if you buy wine on the internet,
if you buy wine on the internet,
and you consume my content which is free,
and you like me in any shape or form,
it is massively important to me
that you sign up for Wine Text.
It is literally the single
best way to buy wine.
What were you asking for the Weekly Vee?
- [Caleb] Big nose.
When you say there's a big nose on this.
- Aromatically.
Has a massive nose.
- [Caleb] Okay.
- Like you can smell stuff.
Here smell this.
You can smell.
You're just smelling one wine right now.
But if we had 50 wines here
and you smelled them all,
some have huge aromatics some don't.
No different than a deodorant.
Think of deodorant.
If you went to the store right now,
and you know how some
deodorants you just open
and it's super aromatic,
you can smell a lot,
and some just seem kinda chill,
especially the new fucking
super healthy shit.
That's what I mean.
- [Caleb] It punches you
in the face versus not?
- Perfume, some is so,
some is over the top.
- [Caleb] Gotcha.
Make sense.
- Big nose.
(snapping)
Is the CMO on a call
right now with Andrea?
- [Man] Yes.
- Okay I need to be on that.
So everybody needs to wait.
What was your plan that
wasn't going to be that?
- [Man] My plan was that you can take
10 minutes and go down.
- No, no, no, I mean
she's already on the call.
- [Man] I get it.
- Bye.
- [Andrea] Okay amazing.
- Thank you.
- [Andrea] Will do.
- [Andrea] Thank you so much.
- Buh bye.
- [Caleb] Real quick.
Just one thing I noticed you went from
I have no idea what the meeting was before
but it was something obviously
completely different,
and then you just very quickly
went into that phone call,
until a total mode of like sales,
but in like a, I don't
know it just seemed,
it's just interesting.
And I think like people
watching are probably curious
how you go from that switch so fast.
- Yeah I think I'm very good
at putting things in compartments,
and I'm very quick.
I have a lot of things in my head,
and I'm able to transition
into the context
and tone and tenor, and you're right.
And I think what we should
challenge ourselves to do
I would have Andrea or Nick or Marcus
watch that video right now,
and I think you should beep out 37 things,
but I think we should show people that.
Because I don't think people understand
there's that version of me too.
And I think that could bring
you guys a lot of value.
And I think we need to challenge ourselves
with Weekly Vee to be
this new great thing,
and I think one of the ways to do that
is to show you more, but
it's gonna require me
to beep 27 or 40 words just now,
so you don't know who that was,
or their names or things that nature.
But you can see what I'm about.
Reason I reached out,
and thank you so much
for being so responsive,
is Andrea and I always
kind of as you can imagine
you've been around the block,
anytime you have nice
conversations or good vibes,
or value somebody, it's
always circling in our world
as a client service provider of like
okay is there ever a time
to have a conversation
with that potential client again.
And I think what's helped us
build us something meaningful
is I think we're less pants on fire,
we try to reach out if we ever reach out,
'cause we surely know
that they'll reach out
if they've thinking about us,
if we have something to offer.
And I think we've had a
really big break through
at Vayner Media.
You have super bowl spots,
so our AOR creative work is exploding.
Our media business is getting
close to dollars in spend.
But 2019 was a year where
we realized a ton of people
wanted to work with us.
But the politics of
you know, first of all,
we are a shop that does media and creative
under one roof, which as you know as a pro
already is an interesting
dynamic because usually
that means two agencies
in the sandbox are being,
it touches their worlds.
- [Client] Yep.
- And then number two,
and kind of what I think
hurt us a little bit with,
we're doing ad hoc proposals,
going back to, ad hoc proposal,
there's like a one, a five,
and a $10 million fee sphere.
That ends up maybe causing sticker shock
or things in this nature.
And then that's one macro example,
there was 150 examples
of ad hoc scope work
that just didn't work.
So we created, we went into CS this week
and literally created more
new business, booked revenue
in the first week of the year than we did
all of last year.
- [Client] Wow.
- Yes.
Thank you.
- [Client] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
And here is how,
we've made it very clear to people
that our creative strategy
product is a person team,
that starts at one fee and that can be
creative in social AOR,
or that can be your AOR.
And then why I'm really calling you,
because I'm not necessarily
intuitively feeling
that's the world we're talking about.
We created seven consulting products.
What we call side dishes.
That are like,
our products that we deem internally as
steal our brains and build it internally,
or give it to the agencies you work with.
And that our thinking is
so progressive and so right
that, that in itself has karma points,
or becomes legion in the future.
And I have always felt like
great vibes towards you,
and recognized without
us really talking that
just by the actions it's
like, okay, it's not,
it doesn't fit just this yet.
But I'm unbelievably excited
about some of the consulting
products we've created, and I
can see based on your business
from a far and just being crafty,
that two or three might be valuable.
And I wanted you to be
educated about them.
So that's really the context.
- Okay so that phone call,
I happen to be on the
other end of the call
with the client, and all I can say is
that Gary is such a master
at being on the move,
and getting right to the point,
and understanding where
a client is immediately.
And then the other great
thing is that he hands it off
to the rest of us to kind of
bring it home if you will.
So he sets things up,
he engages with people
in very real ways.
You can tell that he's
a human being first.
There are no CEOs that can
run at the pace that he does.
But to connect as a real human being.
And that's why I love working with him.
That's why all of us
love working with him.
And that's frankly why our clients
love working with him too.
I think the other thing is
that he's just the master
of all marketing.
He talked about the
way that we're starting
to productize a lot of our,
the things that we're doing
in the consulting world,
and that's because of his background.
He loves to, as he says,
put things in containers.
We even have a menu now
that sort of celebrates a
New Jersey style approach
to consulting, who has that.
But yeah it's really great
to be along side of him,
and innovating everyday.
And learning from him
in all kinds of ways.
(upbeat music)
(laughing)
- You know what I mean?
I like things that come easy.
I actually do, it's a very,
this is why I think I talk
so much about strengths.
I like the things that come easy to me.
For most people they're not a robot
and could work 22 hours in a day,
like I did yesterday.
And by the way, I think
everyone should sleep
seven, and eight, and nine hours.
Yesterday, serendipitously, 'cause I went
to the National Championship game,
and then you gotta go with the fucking
champion LSU players to the club.
If you're in the sports
representation business,
you're fucking in this business.
And then my alarm didn't go off.
And fucking all sorts
of shit happened today.
Punchline is, most people can't do that.
I have natural energy.
- I bet yeah.
- So I'm leaning into my natural energy.
Some people are pretty.
Dustin, I don't know how
that being a pretty life is,
but you know the advantages of that.
(laughing)
- Hey guys I'm Dustin.
The one that Gary was talking to
during the podcast.
Gary likes to really involve his,
whoever's with him pretty much recording
into his content a lot of the times.
But I'm also trying to
coordinate a podcast
which is live and I'm
in my own little zone,
and when he catches me off guard,
so this time it was a
really caught me off guard
'cause I thought he was looking at me
to say something serious, and
then he said some weird joke
about my looks.
(duck quacking)
Yeah (laughs).
(laughing)
- No but really, I really
think that wrapping this up,
there's no way, look do
I believe that people who
are listening who are gonna
be like I'm gonna do that too.
I do not believe that
everyone was given the same
group of talents.
I do think that we should
all challenge ourselves
to be self aware, and try to figure out
the talents, and then if we're lucky
that those talents match
something we're interested
in doing, we have to go
pock committed to that.
(mellow music)
(people talking)
What?
What's today?
- Tuesday.
- It was Tuesday.
(upbeat music)
What up vlog?
7:17 in the morning.
The moon's out like what.
And I'm on my way.
Big fucking Wednesday,
is today Wednesday?
Big fucking Wednesday.
(mellow music)
You're asking me what I'm doing right now?
I'm sitting on the line waiting
for a very senior executive
from a potential client,
I have to give them sensitive information.
So I usually like to deliver that myself
in verbal form not in written form.
Context gets lost on email and text.
So to me face to face is number one,
voice is number two,
when I have to give a
contextual piece of information
that can either be very exciting
or potentially negative.
I think people underestimate
the seven minute call
in a 2020 environment,
and use technology to
disguise themselves from a conversation
they don't actually wanna have.
Which sometimes compounds
a double negative
'cause the context of the bad news
is lost in the text.
♪ Have gone ♪
♪ On hold ♪
Yeah?
- Do you wanna look at two split screens?
You want me out?
- I gotta be in the zone.
Thank you though.
♪ I hope it's not all day ♪
I also don't like how the
split screens are doing,
performing wise.
- Do you wanna test it?
- I think we ought to test them.
(mumbles) doing now.
Every video for the most part,
for like a year or two stayed in a pocket.
Whereas right now,
back to back videos
can be like 1.2 million
and the next one could be 200,000,
it makes me feel like
they're doing a better job.
I don't like when everything's
in the same pocket.
That just feels like, I
would love the algorithms
to get wildly tight.
Give me 4 million when I deserve it,
give me 40,000 when I don't.
Doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
- [John] Yeah.
I learned obviously for me it was a little
different--
- You're doing
strategic spec work.
I do it all the time.
I get paid $200,000 to give a speech.
If somebody calls me right now
and says can you speak in Alabama
let alone the Javits Center,
and I like the audience
and I think it's worth it,
then I'd do it everyday.
- [John] Yeah of course.
- People are too literal.
Everyone's transactional.
What you're doing, what I'm doing,
maybe we have the
advantages of coming from
very low places, and don't
value our theoretical time
or energy like other people.
I don't know what it is
but it's very clear to me
that the biggest things are
people that are thinking,
we're playing chess.
Everybody else is playing checkers.
So, we had a holiday party,
he helped us produce it.
We bartered, I was gonna
jam with him at the party,
but I got caught up with something.
And so I just needed to
deliver on what I said,
which is if you do this
for us and produce this
10 year holiday party,
I'll spend some time
and really jam with you
and that's what we did.
(upbeat music)
I gotta go fast DRock.
- [Man] And not, not miles.
Two hands, two hands up.
- [Gary] Hello it's Gary, how are you?
- So there's this guy, dude with sign.
Posting little like
homeless sign kinda photos
on his Instagram, going
pretty viral and stuff.
And like one of the
things that we like to do
here on team is find
these trending moments,
identify them, and find ways that we can
give our fresh take on it.
So as you can see here,
we kinda had Gary doing
his whole spiel.
Holding up the sign.
And this post like,
dramatically just like,
destroyed and crushed it on Instagram.
Our best performing post of all time.
750K likes.
Before that the max likes was like 370K
or something like that,
on an Ipsy photo or something like that.
And this just destroyed it.
As you can see, I'm over
here working super hard
on coming up with post
images for you guys,
nothing I'm gonna do is
ever gonna beat that,
so you know I'm kinda
defeated a little bit.
Bit it's all good.
But yeah it was a great post,
we had a blast doing it.
If you guys got anymore
ideas of things like that,
that we should do, please let us know,
drop it in the comments.
And yeah that's about it.
(upbeat music)
- So I'm here with my homies Caleb, DRock,
Jason behind the camera, Lou,
aka Frank.
We're waiting on Gary
right now to get out of
(laughs) meeting.
We're gonna film, or we're gonna take
basically three pieces of content,
three pieces of stills,
and an intro for this,
in hopefully under 90 seconds.
- Ideally a Tik Tok clip too.
- Ideally four.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna squeeze it
in 'cause Gary's leaving
after this and then he's
not coming back today.
He's flying to Vegas.
So we're gonna try to squeeze it in.
We'll see what happens.
- [Drock] You look good on camera
- [John] I know.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Be careful.
- You rip it.
- Yeah I know.
(upbeat music)
Okay.
(mumbling)
What?
- Find out on this Weekly Vee.
Cool.
See ya.
- Love you.
- Okay I'll check.
Yo.
- Holy shit somehow we
just acquired two, three,
maybe four pieces of content in the matter
of like 30 seconds.
Real quick before Gary had
to run to another meeting.
David Rock fucking crushed it.
Jason crushed it, John
crushed it, Lou crushed it.
We'll see if I crushed it.
(upbeat music)
- So today's Friday.
I'm in Vegas about to give a speech
to the hearing need
industry believe it or not.
And we're about to launch
the first Weekly Vee,
which was last week's.
Which I'm excited about.
We recorded yesterday's first show called
Interrupted by Gary Vee.
Which I'm excited.
And I'm sorry, I'm listening to this guy
who is reinforcing.
Vlog, I've been really
enjoying this process.
Are you editing this one?
- [Jason] I am.
- Awesome.
So I heard there's been
some good content this week.
Yesterday, I didn't, I
should of done a selfie video
on the plane.
- [Jason] Yeah,
yesterday we had a little
bit with the duct tape.
- Yeah the duct tape.
And you got a little bit from
some of the meetings right?
- [Jason] We did.
- Let's see if I have any--
- [Jason] Tuesday was full
of stuff.
- Anyway that's what we
got vlog.
We're really hacking at this.
We're really passionate
to bring you value.
And hopefully we will continue to do that.
Three, four minutes away from the talk.
What I do in talks is really think about
who the audience is and
I reverse engineer it.
I have a huge advantage because
I've grown up in retail,
I've worked in SMB, small business,
kind of entrepreneur land.
I've worked for the last 10 years
with Fortune 500 companies.
I've worked in Silicon Valley, Global,
I read comments.
So one of the things
that really works for me
is I talk about the state
of the union of the world.
And then I filter it through the context,
and so that excites me.
Extra.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
My friends, LinkedIn,
right this second, right this second,
as we sit here today, I am
day trader of attention.
I like Vine when Vine's big.
I like Snapchat when Snapchat's big.
I like Tik Tok when Tik Tok's big.
I didn't talk about LinkedIn at all.
Now I talk about it everyday.
All I do is look where
there's an arbitrage.
Right this second, LinkedIn, the platform
that you think is just
your business profile,
has become a content platform,
and it is acting like
Facebook did in 2011.
There's a stunning amount of people on it.
If you've been to your LinkedIn recently,
and if you haven't please do,
the content is no longer just business,
it is absolutely everything.
People's opinions, what they're eating,
exercise tips, wine.
It has become Facebook.
The organic reach, meaning
you don't even have
a LinkedIn account, you start an account
for your retail store, for
your store, forget about you,
for your store.
And you start posting content
and people will see it
without you paying for them to see it,
because it's just supply and demand.
The attention on the platform is greater
than the content that people are making.
The biggest mistake that people make
when it comes to marketing is they decide
a platform is not for them.
You decide your customer is not on there.
You decide that Tik Tok
is not for you right now
because that's for 12
to 15 year old girls,
and you're targeting 65 year
old males, let's just say.
What you don't understand
is how communication
and marketing actually works.
Which is if you're thoughtful enough
about the content you make, and you make
a sweet little funny
video of a 15 year old
and a grandpa interacting, it
can bring awareness for you.
The lack of creativity or thoughtfulness,
or understanding of human behavior
has led so many to not
innovate or execute.
The costs are remarkably low.
LinkedIn scares me, how inexpensive it is.
But are you the kind of organization
that is willing to make
seven pieces of content
for LinkedIn a day?
Half this room doesn't make
seven pieces of content
for social media a year.
They take whatever this
organization sends them
and they just post it and
think something's gonna happen.
My friends, I don't know
what you're thinking,
but no matter how remarkable
this three generation
family business is that
makes the best products.
If you are not paying
attention to what technology
is doing to your industry,
you're putting your head in the sand,
and you're gonna let a
tidal wave run you over.
Period.
The world is not going backwards.
Technology and innovation
doesn't care about
how you want it to be.
You must become a practitioner
in communications,
because what the internet
is doing my friends
it is commoditizing everything
but the ability to communicate.
Don't get it twisted.
It's happened.
And how you want it to be
isn't gonna change that.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)
Part two.
- [Man] Gary Vee!
- What's good bro?
You can?
- How'd comment read go yesterday?
- We didn't get anywhere.
- You're the fucking best.
- I appreciate it bro.
- Thank you.
Dude you're amazing.
- Fucking love you.
- Thank you bro.
Thank you bro.
I might be in the mood for some rants.
Listen when I talk about kindness
being the foundation of business success,
a lot of people in the
comment section, DM's,
hit me up with the concept
of Gary you're wrong,
I'm so kind and people walk all over me.
This is a shout out,
this is a call of action,
this is a question to the humans that say,
you're wrong, I always
get walked all over.
I want to ask you a simple question.
When you perceive that you're giving
is that you giving something
with the expectation
that something happens?
Like are you grabbing
Tyler's coffee everyday
but really what you want
him to do is promote you,
and when he doesn't you're like, oh?
Tyler didn't ask you to
get that coffee on the way.
Were you doing something kind
because you expected something in return?
That in the English language
is called manipulation.
Kindness, giving, is giving and being kind
with zero, double zero
expectations in return.
- Can I share a quick thought with you?
- You can my friend, hi.
- I don't know
if it's an original thought.
- Hi.
- Nice to meet ya.
- That's all right.
It's an original thought because
it comes from your filter.
- As long as it hadn't been
said by someone else, yeah.
- Yeah but the angle it comes from,
I actually think all thoughts
are original for that nature,
so nonetheless, go ahead.
- Knowledge is learned
but wisdom is earned.
- Yeah.
- And that's something.
- Punchline being
experience fucking matters.
- [Tanya] Exactly.
- Has to.
- You know it's funny
we were just Facetiming
a football player, my brother and I
have a sports representation business.
When I was 22 and you heard
my story on stage right now,
I was a wiz-kid, it's real, I had it.
- Right, right, right.
- I was an entrepreneurial
talent.
The 44 year old version of me right now
shits on that kid.
And I thought that kid was unstoppable.
- [Tanya] Right, right.
- So yes experience matters, however,
raw talent is raw talent.
Me at 22 destroys tons of 44 year olds
who have plenty of experience,
they just don't have as
much talent as I did.
- [Tanya] And they don't
put it into action.
- Which is part of the
talent execution of business.
- When you thank a soldier for service.
- Yes.
- It's your knowledge
that what they're doing
is dangerous.
- Yes.
- And that they didn't have to do it.
- But you never
walked in those boots.
So that's the wisdom.
They have the wisdom and
you have the knowledge
that it's dangerous.
But they have the wisdom
that it really means.
- Like for example, when I thank someone,
that's more gratitude
of the acknowledgement
of what that's enabling me to do.
- Right, right, right, well that's why we
appreciate you.
- That's right.
Which is the same way I
think about my talents
have enabled thousands,
hundreds of thousands
of people of a shifted mindset.
10s of thousands of people
in economic earnings.
We all play our parts.
Everyone plays their parts in society.
- Rod Stewart said hey I wish I knew
what I know now when I was younger.
Right?
- Everybody wishes that.
- But you take--
- Michael great pleasure.
- Thank you very much Gary Vee.
- Knowledge is learned
and wisdom is earned.
- I'll be honest with you,
I'm unemotional about how the variations
of sentences or sayings are caught on.
- It's easy to remember it.
- To me I'm more worried
about people living it.
- Right, right, right.
You gotta get them to
think about it first.
- Well you've inspired me today,
'cause I do a lot of our social media
and I've been trying to move our company
into that world.
And everything you said today I was like--
- See, see, see.
(laughing)
Keep going.
- [Tanya] Thank you
very much.
- Take care.
Stay well.
(mellow music)
Just now going to a meeting,
going to a meeting with
a potential client.
One of the big hotel groups here in Vegas.
And I'm excited that
Weekly Vee is showing more
parts of that than we make.
Going from a dynamic
meeting around Esports
and the Minnesota Rocker Team,
and hang out with some of the players
in the Esports landscape
to boom get in the cab,
get over to a top executive,
to see if there's some
business for Vayner X,
that's the gallery media group.
Pier Wow 1:37 P.M., or Vayner Media,
or the Sasha Group, or Tracer.
Like living that Vayner X life.
Yo, so I don't know if you guys remember
airport Gary, but he's back on Weekly Vee.
We're wrapping up today's episode.
Just had a great meeting with a bunch
of senior executives at
a very large hotel group.
Here at the airport in Vegas.
Nice sunshine in the background.
Jason and I did it.
Did a nice little trip.
No DRock, no Caleb.
- What up?
- It's Jason and I.
And just a good week.
I hope you guys enjoyed the episode.
A lot going on.
I also threw this banana.
What's good bro?
I just threw this banana on the ground.
You see that banana?
I tried to throw it
from where I was before
into there but it missed so.
Even bananas in the
fucking street Weekly Vee.
(laughs)
Peace.
(happy music)
- It's rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- Yep.
All right.
- Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Yay!
(laughing)
Yeah I'm so pumped up.
I love winning.
(mumbling)
- The first line of the book is,
I started thinking about my hands,
that was my first mistake.
Boom!
You're in man, you're in.
You're fucking in.
- I'm in!
I'm in.
You said boom you're in a little too fast,
if you waited a hundredth of a beat,
I would of been more in.
(mumbling)
There's no clip, really.
- [Man] Look at all the good I'm doing.
- Can you put on the lights?
Is that what she asked?
- [John] Yeah.
Remarkable.
- That was so cool.
(laughing)
Alex do you know what just happened?
I just asked them to turn on the lights
without knowing you did.
- Oh (laughs).
- Yeah this is Wednesday.
(laughing)
- Why is there new app light screening?
- [John] I'm sorry?
- [Caleb] Why was there a
new app light created for X?
- You hearin' this jam?
That Britney Spear's shit baby.
Britney's always back mother fucker.
- [Camera Man] Give me the five.
(laughing)
(group talking)
- By the way real quick.
By the way real quick,
if you didn't know what
that reference was,
you're fired.
(laughing)
If you don't follow me
on Tik Tok fuck you.
A Ton, Jared and I are here,
I don't know why the fuck you're not.
Tell him something Jared.
- What's up brother?
I'll hit you soon.
- So this 1000 just came from a,
I just sat down and played War.
Which is a highly skilled
game in the casino,
if you don't know.
Walk it from my talk.
Won a quick 700.
It was when I felt it and put 500,
when I got down, after I got up and down,
and I got an ace, that was it.
Tyler got hype.
- Yeah I got a little
excited for a second.
- [Gary] There's no, I mean.
- Yeah.
- Jake Leibe just got up.
He was in molasses.
- [Alex] Yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
- People get faster.
- [Alex] Yeah.
(lullaby music)
- Yo.
You good?
Wake up man.
- Oh shit.
What's, what, what?
♪ Cause we're gonna be legends ♪
♪ Gonna get their attention ♪
- I did not say if you are
67 year old Rick in here,
and you're listening and you're like, okay
I'm gonna let my niece do that for us.
I did not say that Rick.
- [Rick] Gary?
- Yes.
- [Rick] My name's Rick.
- Where are you Rick?
(audience laughing)
I've been talking to you
the whole time brother.
(laughing)
I knew you were here Rick.
I've been looking at you
for a fucking decade Rick.
(laughing)
Jason where are you?
Jason?
Get up, go to Rick.
We've been talking about him for 10 years.
(laughing)
People that followed my content,
I legitimately use Rick and Sally.
Please Jason faster Rick has a question.
(laughing)
I mean you're 25 years old, Jason.
(happy music)